for more than a decade the tesseract has
been a crucial force behind the actions
and motivations of many of the marvel
cinematic universes major players let's
take a look at some of the lesser-known
or little remembered facts about the
origins powers and timeline of the story
thread which has bound the Marvel movies
together the tesseract traces its
origins as far back as time itself in
the MCU the Big Bang brought about six
primal elemental singularities time
reality soul mind power and space the
essence of the universe itself was
forged by mysterious cosmic beings into
the Infinity stones the space stone came
into the possession of several ancient
civilizations including the Celestials
at some point its power was harnessed by
a crystalline cube casing the tesseract
the origin of the cube is yet to be
revealed but his purpose was cetain the
raw power of the space stone making it
more easily controllable at some point
Odin the ruler of Asgard came into
possession of the tesseract and housed
it in his own vaults as the crown jewel
of his collection of some of the most
powerful cosmic weapons and artifacts in
the universe
Odin captured and stored in his heavily
guarded vault any weapon or relic he
thought could possibly bring about end
times
also known as Ragnarok and the tesseract
to definitely fit that bill in the First
Avenger
Captain America fights the Hydra Super
Soldier red skull aboard the airship
Valkyrie during the film's climactic
battle as the Valkyrie speeds towards
New York City armed with nuclear
warheads the Red Skull attempts to turn
the tables on cap by bare handing the
tesseract but it doesn't exactly go well
for him a portal opens blasting Red
Skull out of the ship and carrying him
off to parts unknown
while the tesseract burns through the
hull of the Valkyrie and descends into
the depths of the ocean horse Steve
Rogers isn't far behind as the entire
airship plunges into the icy water where
Captain America would remain frozen for
the next 70 years there anything you can
tell us about the tesseract that we
ought to know now
you should have left it in the ocean it
was nearly a decade before Red Skull
appeared in another MCU movie in his
infinity war cameo the character is
portrayed by Ross Marquand of The
Walking Dead Fame replacing the first
Avengers Hugo Weaving drawing the film
is revealed that the space stone
transported red skull to Vermeer and
somehow imprisoned them there the Red
Skull explains that his quest to control
an infinity stone led it to reject him
he's now intrinsically linked to the
soul stone as its guardian but is never
able to possess it sometime after caps
fateful battle with the Red Skull a deep
sea expedition led by Howard Stark
uncovered the tesseract and the cold
waters of the Arctic Ocean while
searching for the body of Steve Rogers
the brilliant inventor had been
instrumental in creating the scientific
process that transformed Rogers from a
scrawny weakling into a super soldier
while in possession of the tesseract
Starck researched and studied its nature
a tesseract surficial first on-screen
appearance comes in a stinger following
2011 slore but the MC use first
tesseract reference is actually in Iron
Man 2 drawing a scene in which Howard's
son Tony is flipping through his
father's notebook the audience is able
to catch a glimpse of a drawing of the
tesseract project Pegasus was formed in
the 1980s as a joint operation between
the United States Air Force and NASA
once the tesseract came into possession
of the US government the project had
been mentioned in other MCU films but
Captain Marvel was the first to shed
more light on the top-secret undertaking
Marvel a Kree scientist posing as human
dr. Wendy Lawson on earth is able to
obtain access to the tesseract and
attempts to harness its power to produce
a Lightspeed engine when a test fighter
flown by Carol Danvers and Lawson is
shot down by crystal force danver
destroys a powerful engine and then the
process absorbs a cosmic power of the
space stone in Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers gains full control of her powers
and memories in 1995 six years after her
crash and subsequent abduction by the
Kree she's then able to force her
pursuers and then cover the tesseract in
the hidden space station in Earth's near
orbit once recovered the tesseract is
kept safe by Marvel's beloved pet cat
juice of course juice is actually a cat
shaped lurkin who stores the artifact in
a pocket dimension in a stomach clerk
ins just so happened to her
humble earthly felines in many ways
except for the many toothy tentacles
that can release from their mouth the
tentacles enabled the deceptively deadly
Fleur kin to devour large prey or
objects to teleport or store in stomach
lining pocket dimensions later goose
walks up the tesseract onto Nick Fury's
desk and the project Pegasus has revived
to further study the object it is soon
relocated to a shield facility in the
Mojave Desert to unlock its full
capabilities the tesseract has appeared
in at least 10 Marvel Cinematic Universe
films that's the same number as Iron Man
and one more than everybody's favorite
Boy Scouts Captain America following the
wild success of Joss Whedon's the
Avengers Marvel began to plot its
storytelling much more carefully than it
had before with this wreak elaboration
Marvel decided to make the Infinity
stones the central story elements of
phases one through three as a result the
tesseract was retcon to contain the
space stone this pivot towards the
Infinity stones as a binding agent of
the MCU will go down in Hollywood
history as one of the greatest
production moves of all time and with a
storyline more than ten years in the
making finally coming to a close with
endgame it may indeed prove to be the
end of an era check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite MCU
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]